Here is a beautiful hand manipulated lace
pattern that takes time.
But it's so worth the effort.
For this example,
we're working over a multiple of 10
stitches and four rows, but you could vary
this depending on your machine and yarn.
Cast-on and knit a row or two.
End with the carriage at the right.
Remove the yarn from the carriage and
hand knit the stitches of the next row.
In my example, I'm knitting four stitches
normally as if they were stockinette and
then elongating the next six stitches.
Make these stitches as large as possible.
Pull them all the way back.
Knit 4 stitches.
Elongate 6, do this all
the way across the row.
Now your carriage is on the right
and the working yarn is on the left,
so you'll need to free past the carriage.
I'm carefully pulling all
the needles out to hold position.
I need to pull down on the knitting
to keep the big loops on the needles
and keep them from catching
on the gate pegs.
I tried using a transfer tool to add
weight as I'm pulling the needles to hold,
but if you watch closely, you'll
probably see a couple of droppedped stitches.
Now, picking up drop stitches isn't
too bad, but I did find an easier way.
Once all the needles are in hold position,
confirm that all the stitches are
on the needles and no loops
are around the gate pegs.
Set the carriage to hold
and free pass across.
Cancel hold, thread up the carriage
and knit a row left to right across
all the stitches. That's rows 1 and 2.
Row three alternates the enlarged stitches.
I'm making the first five large
knitting 4, making the next 6 large,
knitting 4 all the way across the row.
Now, this time I got a little better
at pulling those needles to hold without
dropping stitches.
Instead of using the tool,
which was a bit clumsy,
I used my fingers and I pinched
the knitting below the needles
as I pulled the needles out.
Again, with all the needles in hold, set
that carriage to hold.
Free pass to the left.
Cancel hold. Thread up the carriage
and knit to the right.
You'll repeat these four rows for the
entire stitch pattern. In this photo
I pulled my knitting out over the ribber
so that you could see the stitch pattern,
but you really don't want to knit this
way, especially because you are elongating
those stitches and hand manipulating.
This is a beautiful stitch pattern
for scarves or shawls, and both sides look
great, you can work it on any machine
and you can also use it as an all-over
design or as an insert for just
a touch of lace in your knitting.